j'arrive toujours pas à le croire on va
tomber amoureux d'une nouvelle petite
personne
respirer je commence le compte à rebours
3 2 1
respirer
je ne peux plus mentir un puck
est la seconde où vous direz à votre
femme que vous êtes condamné
vous pourrez plus avoir recours à cette
solution
[Musique]
vous voulez aller le saluer
vers une rue de temps
tout a été transféré tout même les
souvenirs enfouis au fond de votre
subconscient dépens d'autres solutions
il avait de votre famille continuera
comme avant un échange sans aucune trace
qu'est ce que tu as gamme
ce n'est
j'arrive pas décider ce qui est mieux
points
je pensais qu'il me restait plus de
temps
vous offre une occasion unique
après je n'ai pas autorisées à y aller
elle est condamnée
j'ai l'impression de retomber amoureux
d'elle comme au premier jour
j'aime pas ça et moi tu crois que j'aime
ça m'entendre dire que je suis pas moi
parce que tu es pas moi et tu le seras
jamais
[Musique]
je t'aime cameron dernière